even when you mix things up in the
aquatic center
you still get the same result a team gb
win kathleen dawson went first as the
others pushed ahead
by the time adam petey had stormed
through the breaststroke
and james guy had flown through the
butterfly anna hopkins faced the final
leg knowing that u.s star male swimmer
caleb dressel was hunting her down
but she touched the wall first in a
world record time
that's pretty cool there's not many
people that like girls that can say
they've raced against caleb russell so
it was a bit yeah it's a bit daunting to
know he was coming from behind but um
these guys got me such a good lead i
don't think he had any hope catching us
so
yeah it was it was pretty cool to be a
part of they've won so many medals now
that the team gb
swimming squad are the most successful
since 1908
and there's still more medals to be won
the gold was replicated in the triathlon
jess learmonth led them out before
handing to johnny brownlee
the gold medal has always eluded him he
pushed hard on the bike
and had a 10 second lead after his run
next was georgia taylor brown the
individual silver medalist
she ran hard and it over to alex yee
the new star of british triathlon
to do with these guys was yeah really
quite special and to do it with
especially with johnny completing the
set and johnny being one of the people
who kind of got me into the sport and
inspiring me in 2012 to be here two
games later is
pretty insane and for johnny to to
meddle at three different olympics is
yeah pretty incredible as well
and then super saturday swerved off
course dina asha smith
team gb's fastest ever woman didn't
qualify
for the hundred meter final she revealed
afterwards she'd torn her hamstring in
july
and had been battling just to get to the
start line in tokyo
in a statement she said i'm so
disappointed not to make the final
because it's tokyo 2020 like this is
everything i've trained for for the past
two years
but the last few weeks of my athlete
life have been
absolutely insane that hamstring injury
was far worse than anyone really
knew and that means that she's now
pulling out of the 200 meters in these
olympics
but is still hopeful of competing in the
sprint relay
team gb's daryl neeta did make the final
but nobody
could get near the jamaicans in the
space of 10.61 seconds
elaine thompson-hira won a back-to-back
olympic gold
the second fastest time ever seen
tom parmenter sky news tokyo